in ottawa this morning demonstrations
continue for the third weekend in a row
despite it being called a state of
emergency there global's abigail beeman
joins us live from ottawa abigail what's
happening at this point in the morning
good morning while things are are
ramping up let's say for the morning
meaning more and more people are coming
out and heading uh downtown to the hill
or many who are sleeping already in this
area are waking up and getting going for
the day this is after we saw
all kinds of reports of what looked like
a massive party or concert or protest
depending on uh who you are speaking to
and and and what their take on the
situation was but really the bottom line
here is that for the third weekend in a
row uh there is an influx of people to
the capitol
quieter during the week with the
contingent that holds steady throughout
on what's now day 16 but then on the
weekend a large influx of more more
people staying in hotels more vehicles
coming to the downtown core and not just
the downtown core as we you know
mentioned before there are a number of
encampments in other places outside of
just the you know parliament hill and
downtown area the prime minister
stressed friday that protesters are
acting illegally and ontario's premier
issued a state of emergency what's
actually being done to end the protest
so we heard from the prime minister that
everything is on the table justin
trudeau saying that
that that there will be an end to what
he is calling an illegal occupation but
that he wouldn't get into specifics of
how it would end or when it would end
because he is concerned about violence
saying everything is on the table with
the exception of he said that what he
doesn't want to do is call in the
military that's not being seriously
considered right now although he says uh
that they have to be prepared for any
eventuality uh at the provincial level
as you mentioned the premier declaring a
state of emergency talking about very
significant fines jail time uh we went
out and spoke with quite a few
protesters after that announcement had
been made not a single person that we
spoke to was deterred by that concerned
by arrests or fines saying that they
they were there for a as long as it
takes is is the message that you hear
on the streets here and what that means
for many people that we've spoken spoken
to is until the mandates are lifted they
say that they're not going anywhere we
will see uh if if that changes and then
at the municipal level you have the city
of ottawa which uh announced yesterday
afternoon that they will be seeking a
court injunction of their own talking
largely in the text of the letter that
they released that this has to do with
bylaw violations but in terms of any
major scale enforcement you're certainly
not seeing that the last update from
police they had issued 1700 tickets we
know that police are handing out tickets
in some cases but there is nothing going
on in terms of a large-scale
police enforcement that is focused on
actually getting people out of here
okay wow okay thank you so much for the
update this morning and your time
abigail